i'm glad i don't
invite women to get me to see me get my
hair cut
but to think that once they spin me in
there and they're doing this and they
they pump me up and i'm just there
they're looking like oh yeah you're not
even tall enough for a trip child you're
literally not tall enough for a trip
[Music]
what up party people what's good what's
good what's good
all right this is the place to be
with fire lord forex and jimmy d
on this monday eve
i don't know what else to say um right
guys i'm just going to be fourth coming
from the jump it's going to be a little
bit of a shorter episode today i think
we're about to get kicked out of the
building times against us yeah times
against us today they're shutting down
the building early so we're going to try
and give you the juicy juice in in
around 40 to 45. okay
so give us your time
um and let's run through the thing so
obviously you know what to do if you're
watching on youtube um
two fingers of death flick the bean uh
and ring that bell so notification bell
keep that on so you know when we're
posting yeah mom um alongside with that
click the subscribe button um and like
and chirp sitting in the comments as
always um we hope you're slaying
head on over to patreon.com
forward slash shits and gigs um
if you want to get into the episodes if
you if you're jumping in today i think
oh what now 40 minutes i can't handle
that for the whole week bro it's all
good head on over to patreon
forward slash the gigs all right
every thursday you're going to get
another episode you can breathe easy now
it's light it's it's calm you're
patterned
um
as well as all the bonus gifts that we
get on top of there but without any
further ado guys we're going to tune
into your boyfriend's buckle up he's
going to hit us with a fun fact and
we're going to boogie you from there
let's go bro
over the course of an illustrious
20-year career kobe bryant rest in peace
earned an impressive 320 million dollars
directly from on court salary as one of
the highest paid players in nba but one
investment over the course of seven
years made him 400 million dollars 1.25
times more than his entire career
earnings
back in 2014 he acquired a 10 stake in a
sports drink company called body armor
this week it was announced that
coca-cola will acquire the company for 8
billion
his investment has had a 13
13 000
gain in the last seven years and the
summer 400 million dollars will now be
inherited by his family
mad money
money
that's that mamba money mamba money
that's that mamba money bro smart guys
bro bringing in more money than has ever
made whilst he's not even alive
come on man
um nars has done something similar as
well nar's invested in nasa's like a
billionaire yeah i think he invested in
i want to say he's bitcoin
or something else but he did it i think
it was bitcoin like back a day before it
was even popping he invested i want to
say certain light for him like 200 bucks
and now he's it's skyrockets like 200
mil something stupid yeah something
stupid the inventor of bitcoin is like
13th richest man in the world right now
wow yeah
wow i didn't bro this crypto game thinks
i'm inventing something like that i
don't know bro it's all a lot of bitcoin
yeah it don't it don't even make sense
brother it literally doesn't these
crypto dons are on a different wave
different yeah that's the thing as well
you just wish that you had they always
say like oh if you would have just put a
grand in it when it came i said if i had
that kind of money i would have put a
grand in it
exactly i would grant it just shell out
yeah
something that may or may not work yeah
yeah it's
that's a tough way to live
it's a tough way to live but um
yeah i'm gonna live day by day
oh and i say day by day check by check
yeah when you're living hand to mouth
like me
paycheck to paycheck
i ain't got a grant to just dash out
like that you just can't you can't do
things like that yeah it's true man
props um i guess you said last time you
had a question for me in it oh yes i do
um
it's a very silly question
always it's it's a lose-lose
all right go on would you rather
get one banged
in the first round of your profession no
who would you rather
get one banged from the in the first
round of a professional boxing match
tyson fury
or deante wilder
tyson fury
you'd rather get one banged by tyson
than deontay yes
yes obviously yeah it's a loser i'm
getting knocked out by either of them
yeah but vamp deante wilder
he takes the soul out of people
he strips the soul from people fam
he's a like i don't think you get it bro
he's not man out of one punch before
yeah all of his fights ended knockout
his right hand is is the scariest thing
known to man i mean he's not banging me
bro tyson all day hundred percent
hundred percent
um
speaking of tyson his brother's got the
uh the jake paul fight in it i don't
even know he had a brother i think it's
oh tyson fury i think
his brother bro elsewhere yeah and jenny
thought was his cousin tommy yeah he's a
brother okay his half brother they got
same dad okay okay okay okay um but
there's pressure on my man fam i've seen
both um
so his dad
went live saying basically if he doesn't
he said he has to knock
jake paul out
he said a win is not enough unless he
knocks him out
he said if he doesn't knock him out he's
retiring him
he said i'm not gonna let him be a boxer
anymore if he doesn't knock this
youtuber out because he's a youtuber
because he's a youtuber damn tell me if
he's a professional boxer he is he's a 7
he's 7-0 i think professionally yeah
yeah so he needs to knock
jake paul out otherwise
don't come back fam tommy's got
shoulders oh yeah he's got shoulders
i've seen i've seen him oh in person
i've seen him seen him but he's got shot
he's broad i'll swear bro yeah it
doesn't it doesn't look it because he
looks slim yeah he looks slim like he
looks like he's got shoulders on a slim
person he's fan he's a triangle i'll
swear yeah he's
[Laughter]
yeah she's doing boston as well i swear
she's like creative director or
something like that yeah
yeah she's a million she makes like a
million month or something stupid like
that nah she don't she makes pee brother
she makes pee brother it makes no sense
yeah i'm a little love island yeah now
she makes gorilla all of them men that
come out of there are loaded this makes
no sense that was done he does the most
yeah yeah yeah he does the most bro
he makes money money
all of them he sings now no is that a
guy that sings now yeah he does
everything yeah he does everything i see
him on tick tock he's making songs he
[ __ ] i tell you who who was i saying
this to the other day
one prayer
who impresses me weirdly and i say
impresses but like he intrigues me
is the what's his name the white don
from love island
is it jack fowler is that his name
jake jackson jack jack yeah it's jack
valley yeah yeah he doesn't seem like
your typical roll your eyes love island
guy but he's doing bits now he's been
doing bits so since he left he's been
dude he's been doing bits since he left
so but i don't relate him same way i
wouldn't relate tommy fury to love
island fair enough and molly even though
you know she's love island she's so busy
yeah yeah and so booked that is
irrelevant now she makes so much money
that love island is completely
irrelevant um but yeah she'll never win
that's how crazy is bro but yeah that
jack fowler like that amber yeah she is
she she stinks of love island
because she doesn't do anything of
substance do you know what i mean
that we know of truth that we know of
that we know of yeah
all right these men yeah all right i
actually take that back i said that back
because that was aggressive she's very
[ __ ] aggressive bro i was aggressive
that we know of
calm down allegedly
that that was rude of me that was rude
of me think something like she does
think of love island though no offense
man that's just that's just the vibes
that i'm getting yeah
she thinks of love and yeah she just
seems like she's just mad tabloidy do
you know what i mean anytime
you see her name it's not that she's
doing [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah it's the
[ __ ] she's greelish is yeah or
science
i think yesterday or today yeah yeah
yeah
it's just like that stinks of love
island that stings of love island it
does it does um
who else thinks that i tell you who
doesn't think of light i love i think
because they're so banging is them twins
oh what [ __ ] eve and
i can't remember it's even
banging i don't know
i see him as ting one and ting two i
don't know their names bro i don't know
anything about him even they're all i
know
i can't remember the bread that was with
her in the show the big black brand did
you watch that season or not i've never
watched any season i watched that season
and i think i watched the season either
before that or after that but i've only
seen like two full seasons of the year
yeah but that was one of the seasons i
watched
and she was with i can't remember what's
her or the other one i currently wanted
to cover yeah um one of the things was
with one big black bread dot um
bodybuilder bro
clearly it was only there to smash it
like he was data to smack those sheets
obviously
when they left yeah yeah obviously they
didn't do anything in the villa but when
they left they were dating for a bit
blah blah blah
um and then they parted ways but all i
just know he was there to clap cheeks
let's clap cheeks because you know well
you might not know but
um towards the tail end of the show once
you're in a couple
um your parents come to see you or that
your loved ones come to see you come
busy yeah so whilst uh ting one or ten
two was with this my man her family came
or their family came
she they look nothing like their parents
because obviously all this body
augmentation yeah yeah yeah of course of
course no offense their parents are
buzzed i'll swear they're not going to
age well they're not to be
all right yeah yeah but you could tell
that when my man's parents came they
were so disappointed in him they were
african yeah
so disappointed
he was dreading the moment yeah the
parents had to come through because it
wasn't my life it wasn't like a brother
and his boy it was his mum and dad that
kid nah nah you could just tell
and i'm i'm nigerian i know
i know you i know what parents are
thinking in certain situations
hilarious
if he could erase that yeah he would
that's the one thing he would erase from
the whole show wow i know that for a
fact that's shameful i know that for a
fact ah i hate that for him i hate i
hate it for him yes like i love him i
can imagine what it's like
imagine what it would have been like
your mum knows like you're just trying
to smash you're either you're trying to
smash or you're not even trying to or
you're disgracing my family one of the
two it's one of the two because i don't
understand what you're doing
that's basically what his mom was
thinking while she was on the show i
don't understand what you're doing here
because there's no one here that i can
imagine her mom saying like whispering
is it there's nobody here that's yeah
yeah there's no one that you could bring
to our yard yeah so what are we playing
we play what are we doing here yeah yeah
yeah yeah no one's tickling my fancy and
i don't understand why you're why you're
here you need to come home now yeah when
we land yeah this is over yeah yeah dump
her because this is over you can't bring
her to the dunya
now
i'll filthy banging
they're banging they're filthy bagging
even what's the other one's name i don't
[ __ ] know bro oh they're just oh
you know how i know you think they're
banging you've liked every single one of
their pictures
i don't follow any of them if they pop
up on my explore thing
i don't know because i don't know why
but i never know who it is
i just see banging on my explore page
and i think oh yeah and then as soon as
it opens up i clog who it is and then i
see light by food you had standard just
you
no one else i know not even foo had a
seven others yeah fu had
just you like all of their people
they
you know who else is banging oh again
you've not watched the show but in the
same i think it's the same season
maura
i don't know that as well i'll show you
ah bro maurice slim she's very same i
think she's
i want to say irish
irish or welsh it's one of those yeah
one of them gaelic things sex appeal
brother [ __ ] me eyes [ __ ] me eyes all
right let's go
she's
she wouldn't she's not any of our types
okay yeah
but
there's something about her brother
that's that aura that energy aura more
as well with the aura
let's go more with the aura she knows
what she's doing yeah he knows what
she's doing you know who actually
speaking of who um
again allegedly
but one that i feel everyone thought was
going to be a gazillionaire by now and
just doesn't seem to be is ovi
yeah bro he's fallen off the flap he was
the
guy of guys he was a mr love island fam
he was literally when he came out of the
thing
into if they were taking polls
over and anthony joshua it was
twitter was busy with his name oh he was
trending daily wow i remember i went to
um
i went to afrom nation the first time
foundation 2019 i went with a group of
my boys and a group of my boys boys so
all of us went together so i didn't know
some of them when i went there yeah we
just all stayed in the same spot there's
one bread i won't say his name because i
don't know if he would want me to say
his name that we were there with
he's six four right
ov six five six six i believe um and i
think on the first or second night
um we had come back home and he was just
talking to us about his day and blah
blah and how everything was he said he
got moved to you by a chick and one of
the first questions she asked him was
how tall are you
obviously him feeling sweet yeah six
four in it and then she was like
not as tall as ivy then kissed her teeth
and walked away
six four is everything what do you mean
kissed her teeth and walked away nah fam
ovie was crushing the game bro the thing
over what's her name brother there's one
thing that ovi was why were talking
about love islands beyond me i don't
know but there's one thing that ovi was
dating in the show or i was matched with
in a show
[ __ ] she was i can't remember her name
i'm never going to remember because i ah
i will show you after this but
whoever watched that season knows who
i'm talking about physique
brother
one of them once um
she's got a sister as well but her
sister wasn't on the show
fair play all right say let's say
and i was thinking this is perfect yeah
they're gonna bang that's all i was
thinking they're gonna that's all i was
thinking when i see couples like that
what i think all i think was destiny
that's all i think on on road
if i see a buff buff couple you're like
you guys have sex
that's all i think
there
i
was
um
last weekend i went
this is such a random place to think it
my little sister was in a play
last week and i went to go watch her
yeah and there were this couple there
got to watch their kids yeah and it was
a mixed race girl yeah braids yeah like
nose job fake lips
body this is the mom this is the mom
thank god okay this is the ma oh
no no no no i'm talking about parents
watching okay okay and the dad white guy
yeah
beard
neck tattoos everywhere
um and just he looked like just come out
a pen but he was a softie because their
ute was on their daughter he was crying
i think
yeah but anyway i've seen them sit
together and i think i know youtube yeah
yeah i can just
imagine it yeah i can just
tell by the energy here yeah and the
appearance yeah you man bang and you're
both buff yeah and it's so weird that
that's in my head yeah it's in my head
that's exactly there you see i can see a
buff couple and i think
man [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah i'm not even thinking
about [ __ ] her yeah i'm thinking of
especially when they have traits that
you know that they find attractive in
each other let's see if she's got a body
and he's just wham or something like
that you just think are you you're only
here to [ __ ]
you're made
i get so excited about pathetic little
things like that i know exactly what you
mean i love exactly what you mean yeah
i'm here
especially in places i work obviously i
see couples galore and when i see a buff
couple that's all i think i'm thinking
damn bro
you guys do the thing
you and it's weird because
if i see her first or if i see her first
and he sees me see her he's probably
thinking i'm looking at her yeah but
when i see him
i don't know whether he
i i give him the i give everyone like
the the wagon kind of thing yeah
but it's like he doesn't know that i'm
thinking i'm just doing this for youtube
i'm doing it like you man you're just
smiling like yeah yeah you know what's
inviting like tonight after a few babies
i know you might have banged in yeah
once you order your third sex on the
beach i know what's going on tonight i'm
dropping that 6 out of b to the table
yeah
for both of you how's your night going
guys yeah
and they're just their hands are just
better
or she you know when she she she brings
the chair closer well you know when he
reaches over and drags the chair on from
under the table and her legs are folded
and he just rubs that soft knee
sexuality oh
jesus christ you already know what's
going down i'm such a perv
i'm such a perfect for banging couples
bro
oh
[ __ ] all right cool so guys shed some
love
um with our boys over at manscaped okay
christmas is just round the corner
you've got to give a gift to get a gift
okay and the gift is smooth genitals bro
that's the gift that keeps on giving
smooth genitals
so
all you need to do guys is head on over
to mansgate.com
find the performance package 4.0
it comes with the weed whacker
it comes with the perfect
led equipped anti-nick equipped
waterproof waterproof equipped
trimmer
it's the best thing on the market it's
literally the best it is the best thing
in the market i mean it's only helped
what two million men worldwide something
give or take um i mean nothing nothing
major just like couple couple mil
sunlight saturn light so guys
if you're sick and tired of your girl
complaining about a razor burn
performance package okay girls if you're
sick and tired of your man
in the shower just ah
yeah and he doesn't let you s suck him
off for about three weeks while it heals
performance package
this is this
we're going to go from rubbing nuts
to
clapping cheeks bro soft smooth clappage
so guys manscape.com
forward no not forward slash
the code is sng 20 off free shipping
worldwide you already know what it is
i'm i just i just get happy for other
people yeah i know what you mean i get
very happy for other people like yeah
man
we love to see it
let's go 100 love we love love
jokes that is very good but what i
thought we got
okay
i've been laughing too much i can't
breathe
right
i want to get into more x
because
the the trail is just going oh yeah i
forgot about that train can't be stopped
and they just keep on coming
um
i know before we were talking about how
the men just weren't pulling it out
still not really you know really still
not really all of these ones i got from
from women again
from women again and i saw guys trying
to contribute and it was just whack
um
so to talk about again so as you guys
might know is
last time i did the x
these x were taken from the comments of
an ick video
[Music]
these icks are taken from the comments
of that
comment video
so this this is and they get worse
progressively worse i saw the first one
laughed and stopped ready start reading
calm calm calm down couldn't i couldn't
do it to myself yeah yeah fam right
i'm going to take a swig of water let me
sit up yeah yes
atrocious
women hit that's why it hurts fam they
really do right
some more tick tock x yeah
starting off basic
when he's in the backseat of the car and
looks through the small window
in them two doors and you could just see
him figure it
nah
that's not fair
i've seen one very similar saying when
he's in a two-door car and he has to get
out from the back oh and step over the
the forefoot
embarrassing
i can see it and i can automatically
think it's a nick oh fam oh and you know
he's tripping over the seat belt oh how
do you know he is ah you know when he
steps i have to do that double help the
camera
he gets one foot out and he has to like
hop his other leg out shameful
shameful get a license
get a license that's what she's saying
that's basically what she's saying get a
license get a license fam all right
that's embarrassing
um
this one's out of all this was me
earlier when he tries to throw a paper
ball in the bin and misses that was you
earlier it just
it fumbled uh you know when you practice
it three times
and then whap and uh a full shot is not
fair
right
god god
stop it
i can't read it
right
i need to say this with a straight face
right
when he goes to the bathroom
farts and it echoes in the toilet
do you know why i'm so annoyed about
that do you know why i'm so annoyed
about that because you've been to my
donut you've been to my yard so you know
my yachting yeah yeah yeah yeah my
bathroom
toilet
is literally a thin wall between my
bathroom and bella's bedroom yeah yeah
yeah so
if i'm taking a [ __ ] in the morning yeah
yeah yeah
i have to be very conscious yeah yeah
yeah of the noise level especially if
i'm not i always play music in it we've
discussed it yeah we have we have guys
shower yeah disgusting
whatever yeah
good memory bro disguise and [ __ ] with
showers we've talked about this before
so you have to either put the shower on
or play music yeah if i'm not doing
either yeah
i'm just on a toilet like
fam
the worse you clench up
and try and ease it through the worse it
gets
the shit's play with that yeah
when he's lactose intolerant
let me enjoy
let me endure my own ailments isn't it
it's not my fault it's literally not my
fault
[Music]
trying to spoon when he's shorter than
you
you've probably experienced that before
i haven't i've never experienced it but
i've been there i bet you have been
there ah i've been there nah she's five
eleven oh
no not was but the girl i've seen at
that time yeah five eleven and you're
five nine five nine
yeah
your legs are by her calf
do you remember
this is so embarrassing
do you remember
do you remember how i told you how she
used to lips be sometimes
bend down
what did she do she said that ronaldo
stance
which one before taking a free kick
spread the legs wide
no no no no no no we are breaking up
from there if you had
or back shot she used to spread her
stance to lips you
or backshotted oh no
the spread
i don't know how you affirmed that as a
man you're more of a man for just
putting up with that
i wouldn't be able to look myself in the
mirror oh bro and she was banging of
course it was worth it but
there's no girl on planet earth that's
paying enough for
for me to watch her spread her legs
so that her head drops so she can lips
me face to face
if maya drama was 6-1
my job no fam no one i don't think you
think i'm playing i think you are no i'm
fam
that's so embarrassing for you yeah but
obviously millions of people know now
but
if it's just you and her in the room big
man you're doing anything you want oh
fair play fair play it's only because
you're saying out loud you're thinking
about it so is it something that like
she tried to style out
or she made it very obvious as i'm
shooting i mean i wouldn't necessarily
say she tried to start it out and i
wouldn't necessarily say she tried to
make it obvious it was just something i
think she automatically just did yeah
yeah she's probably used to this game
she's tall as [ __ ]
for a girl also why is a five foot
eleven goal eight foot three
it doesn't make sense it doesn't make
sense so five foot nine girl is taller
than a five foot nine guy oh one million
percent doesn't make sense heels aside
heels aside bro they're tall as [ __ ]
it's their torso
yeah yeah
long fast
oh this one
spoke to me it was hilarious
when he has to sit with his legs
together to balance the plate on his lap
that's the one i read and died do you
know how many times i've done that fam
at the barbecue paper plate just
i've done that one million times bro one
million times bro and i'm thinking
ah i see it oh it's so embarrassing i've
sort of an egg for myself every time i
lie down every time i watch something on
tv something rather i like to lie down
and if i've got a couple snacky snacks
let's say popcorn for example like m ms
and i'm like
and it just rolls down my chin into my
beard oh no i look at i look at it
falling on the floor yeah imagine a
yacht looking at me fam that must be in
it fam i got that one
i get that when i'm at the cinema yeah
and i go fistful at a time with the
popcorn and when the lights come on in
the movies on and i've got a puddle of
popcorn in my lab
i can't imagine a ting seeing me like
that just look at you like looking down
and i've got [ __ ] in my business all of
my life you [ __ ] scumbag
you [ __ ] scumbag oh the what bro the
worst one because when i have things in
my beard like light things i can't feel
it yeah yeah
i can't feel it yeah it's annoying the
worst thing for me every morning yeah
after i eat this i go into miriam and
have a look porridge
oh
before i leave the yard
because of that
it's annoying it's annoying but that
much i hate that with the beard that
like one drop will stay crystallized in
your beard for a day forever fam if i
take a drink because my mouth is loose i
don't know if i've had a stroke it's
satin but some a lot of times when i
take a swig it just drips down yeah yeah
when you're thirsty faster
and i have to lean over i'm like oh [ __ ]
and i'll just carry on talking i've just
got spreckels found sprinkles of water
all in my beard it's so embarrassing
[ __ ] hate
liver shot fam
when he tries to put his boxes on but
trips when he gets a foot stuck
that's me that's me on a daily basis
yeah and your dick and balls are just
out
you kind of fall over
your arse is out your dick is just
slapping against the inside of your legs
no man ah
oh same quick as long as it's on i i
don't care once this one i don't care oh
[ __ ] sake
um specific
oh we spoke about this one before
when he uses the or that emoji [ __ ]
shame on you shame on every man that
uses that
you know we've seen over speaking though
mandom shouldn't be using that
see no evil speaking no evil
shouldn't be using that
that's it
you know we were sitting on the street
from a monkey
that's the thing no you said it too
fluid fam that's making me itch oh my
god mandom can't be used oh bro this
one's the peakest one i've ever
read and two people commented it so you
know it's real
femme
when the barber has to pump his chair up
[Laughter]
nah
nah
wow
i see two separate people comment that
shame as if that's an ick that's a joke
i've not even thought about that before
i'm glad i don't
invite women to get to let me get my
hair cut
but to think that once they spin me in
there and they're doing this and they
they pump me up and i'm just there
they're looking like oh yeah you're not
even tall enough for a trip child you're
literally not tall enough for a trip
that is hilarious
i can't breathe right now hang on
my neck is itching to pieces
ah
you men are too cutthroat ladies oh
hundred percent two cut throat hundred
percent two cut through it's not fair
it's not funny it is funny but it's just
not at the same time it's not fair and
not funny jesus christ that was
hilarious
oh [ __ ] my life have you got any more
yeah no
no for more fun now there will be some
next week okay okay but let me get this
on the [ __ ] done gang it's not oh
[ __ ]
that hurt me right
all right cool this is kind of mellow
right
so
um i've got no mind the [ __ ] for you
guys i was dating a guy for eight months
everything was great until he got very
possessive and manipulative towards the
seventh month
he wouldn't let me see my friends would
demand to know where i was every minute
of the day
this guy used to go through my phone
weekly whoa
i had this i hate that she put this i
had nothing to hide so i wasn't too
bothered you should be 100 you should be
bothered regardless i don't care if i
just bought the phone
don't touch it
um i started to get a gut feeling he was
doing things on the side so one time i
decided to check his phone i found
multiple messages to other girls and
planning to meet up
um
we went back and forth for a while and i
ended up finishing the relationship
after this i had a little ting with
someone and we banged
my ex started to try and chat to me
again month or so after this he found
out and went off at me saying i'm
disrespectful and a slag
uh because i knew he was still about me
um
i was like man we broke up but uh he was
having none of it am i the [ __ ]
to to be honest for me i just seem so
basic and open a shot i don't even
understand so give me the rerun again
she was seeing a guy i went for the
phone
and now they're not together and she's
[ __ ] a guy and he found out and now
he's hating so he wasn't yeah he was mad
possessive
she wasn't feeling it she got a gut
feeling that he was doing a thing so she
went through his phone
um found out that he was chatting to
other girls
they had a few arguments eventually she
decided you know what i'm done
then after that she banged the next guy
my man found out about it and then
beefed her saying you knew i was still
about you
et cetera et cetera you're a slag and
you're disrespectful and all this stuff
and she's saying um basically she's
asking am i the [ __ ] for sleeping
with someone else no mike's was still oh
wow what's what are we talking about
this is why i say i think
when and this is not like an insult this
is like genuine when they're send when
they're writing these am i the [ __ ]
obviously they're saying it in the
moment like it's heat at the moment or
they're in the midst of whatever's
happening
but
they should before sending it read the
thing fam because it's clear as day
you're not the [ __ ] fam it's so
incredibly basic that i really don't
understand
what we're what we're looking for
exactly
like oh all we can say is
your ex is
manipulative he's jealous and he wants
his cake he wants to have his cake and
eat it that's all we're getting from
this
so you're not the answer for [ __ ]
someone waiting after you yeah yeah big
man you're single
you're a single person you had sex with
another single person i don't understand
what you're asking
like
i the only thing i could think of
obviously he's manipulative
and he's controlling so he may have
he maybe he may have spun it in a way
like say we're broken up
but we're gonna die together
so don't even think about it like if you
don't want to see me you don't want to
be with me you don't like me that's fine
but just don't disrespect me
yeah i mean let the furnace turn down
let let's let this love burn to ashes
before you go and kill me
basically that's what a toxic guy like
that would say so that's why she sent
the ticket yeah that's what she's
sending am i also because he seems
caught up i thought i was single baby
girl you are single you'll do what you
want also how [ __ ] did he find out about
it anyway
probably socials i don't know the small
town mentality thing i swear half of
these amazing [ __ ] come from
villages yeah because some of the stuff
they say i'm just like what you want
about how are they finding [ __ ] out and
this and that yeah it all comes back
around it's like how do considering he
you went through his phone afterwards
and he was planning to link things
why is he why is he mad big man why is
he found messages in your phone saying
that you are trying to link things
it's the conversation and now we're not
even together when i've done my thing
you were doing your thing when when when
you were in a relationship i did my team
when you're single
block like delete i'm blocking you
like everything
that correlates to the term delete yeah
it's you
that's it done i don't yeah i hate these
kind of ones as well it's open and shut
yeah and like
speaking of this i was actually talking
to the boys about this
yesterday or the day before and we're
talking about like
people being so manipulative
and like entitled during a breakup
process in terms of like you know like
breaking up over text
and like i've only ever broken up with
people have a text you've said it on
here before only and i will continue to
do it that way
because once i decided i want to be with
you anymore when i see them yeah i don't
want to see you
and be more uncomfortable
and then people like to always put it
like oh wow you don't even respect me
enough to sit me down and do this with
me properly and it's like
[ __ ] your respect like i don't want to
have anything to do with you anymore
yeah i literally don't i have no
interest in you yeah um but people love
to like manipulate [ __ ] whereas like
people can't just hold the l like being
dumped is a [ __ ] l oh 100 but
it is what it is you can sit me down you
can text me you can call me you can
facetime me yeah you can take me on
holiday for [ __ ] sake it's gonna be
the same end result like you're telling
me you don't want to see me again
that's fine like i just don't understand
and the whole like
on top of that is all is like um that's
where the whole
well that's what my perspective is is
like the guilt tripping i've had when
breaking up with girls makes me feel so
bad that i end up agreeing to be friends
with them
and then all they want to do is try and
[ __ ] me more
and then just try and cling back to this
old [ __ ]
it's so crazy bro i've had to learn the
hard way like four times
yeah i don't i'm not an easy learner fan
i hear you bro um but yeah from now on
well i say from now on i don't even
intend to do it again but
um
yeah
the whole breakup thing needs to be more
savage
it needs to be more savage i think it
needs to be more savage just in terms of
like the general like i feel like if
people are going to break up with people
then they need to break up with people
oh so it's all ties are cuts
especially like this if you don't think
your partner can handle it
and they're gonna be this kind of person
like obviously from the sounds of it it
didn't go smooth when she locked off my
man 100 from the way he's acting up it
clearly didn't go smooth so if you
notice what's going to happen i feel
like you need to take ownership of the
breakup and be like big man feel how you
want to feel we're done
otherwise [ __ ] like this happens yeah
yeah yeah yeah true if you would have
locked him locked him she wouldn't you
would never have to deal with this you
would never have to deal with abuse from
your ex about you [ __ ] another guy
like why were you even talking to your
ex again anyway
my mum was on that young track and tracy
tries to find where she can drink
something on the tracking man said fire
my iphone
yeah i ain't got time for that i
remember i used to have an x that used
to hacking to do my phone my iphone i
think you told me about this type of fam
uni
pre uni
uni ish i actually don't remember i
remember because i remember it happened
while i was at home
but i can't remember if it was during
uni time or maybe just after you time
but anyway i use that i remember i had a
a girlfriend and literally i was
sleeping at my boys yet i went on a
night out
uh i went back to my boy's house i was
asleep on his sofa
and i was awoke
by the by the loudest noise i've ever
heard in my life i thought something was
guy i don't i didn't know why i panicked
family yeah i had no idea what it was my
iphone noises disgraceful i didn't even
look at my phone because i thought it
was a fire alarm yeah yeah and then
eventually when i looked at my phone and
i saw it was to find my iphone thing and
then i saw i had like nine missed calls
um
from my girl at the time and then like i
rang and was like well this was like
four in the morning at this point and i
was like what the [ __ ] she was like
where are you where are you obviously
you're not home because
that's crazy when you actually think
about it yeah
i didn't think how crazy it was at the
time yeah you wouldn't you don't because
you're in it when you're in it you can't
see straight yeah yeah and even i don't
even know i can't remember if you meant
i i can't remember at the time even if i
told you a lot or not i probably didn't
tell you
because i i would like to think that if
i did tell you someone would have stood
up and be like get out of there yeah
because that's crazy talk yeah yeah yeah
yeah like even if you haven't heard from
me
like unless it's
like we gotta play this like the police
unless it's been 24 hours have you heard
from me we're not filing a missing
person's report
don't hack into my iphone and try and
find where i am like if you ain't heard
from me in a few hours
leave it just let me be just leave it
it's only a couple hours it's only been
a few hours i'm just taking a cat nap
and my boy so far
and then
it got so heated at that point that i
actually had to leave my boy's yard at
four and i couldn't even go back to
sleep because she was blaring so much in
my ear
talking about oh you're a [ __ ] lie
you're trying you're like you're
cheating you're out doing something that
i had to be like you know what fine i'm
gonna go home
so i literally had to stay on i didn't
have to but i ended up staying on the
phone to her and just walking home
whilst on the phone to her until i got
home like see i'm home now i've
literally stayed on the phone to you
from inside his house to leave his house
to walk home to going home like are you
satisfied
vertically like yeah cool bye
unless you're in it sometimes it's hard
when you say in retrospect you're like
wow yeah that's crazy yeah but when
you're young and dumb yeah full of calm
yeah you do damn [ __ ] you do man you
ignore the reddest of reds yeah man
you're not the most like thing
chicks love like
young naive chicks
and guys actually
love red flags when you can justify it
as passionate love
do you know what i mean
when he or she acts like a [ __ ]
nutcase
but they twist it like oh it's just
because i love you so much
the party the third party they love it
yeah they live for it
chicks especially they love drama
they [ __ ] love drama i can't deal
with it they adore drama in their
relationship
it pisses me the [ __ ] off especially if
is under the guise of love yeah
and passion
when he's under the guise of love and
passion they're here for it
the young things i can't [ __ ] stand
it um but anyway guys
short but sweet apologize for the short
episode but we'll be with you on
thursday on patreon
um
tell a friend to tell a friend to jump
on and uh
if not guys we'll see you next week
love love love love love going going
[Music]